el abuelo
hola bienvenidos al programa del
castores cibernético desde montreal un
saludo a todos nuestros oyentes
internautas que nos siguen a través de
facebook del canal youtube y también de
nuestro sitio web eres en este punto sea
hoy tenemos una sorpresa paloma martínez
bienvenidas un gusto gracias y mucho
[Risas]
se me olvida como aprender
cómo están ustedes con un poco de hambre
trabajamos a la hora de comer
qué barbaridad es que nos pagan extra
por eso fue fundamental estaba acordado
porque he visto una fotografía hoy en
radio canadá el servicio en lengua
francesa y me acordaba de un viejo
profesor que solíamos tener en la
universidad y yoigo
habló que era claro que era un profesor
de metodología excelente profesor y me
acordé hace tantos años ya en una
llegaba a fin de año y él dijo qué les
parece si hacemos el examen en mi casa
en vez de venir a la universidad
entonces todo el mundo dijo que claro
que sí y había que llevar un plato había
que llevar una comida adentro
entonces digamos no llevaba su plato
también había mucho olor a marihuana me
acuerdo en esa época y eso que todavía
no estaba legal
bueno hoy está y me sorprendió un plato
en particular y que todo el mundo lo
comentaba que era era un alumno un
compañero del action y había llevado a
la famosa tur tierra que es una tarta de
carne se podría decir si el de la
religión de que ve esa región que es
famosísima y que tiene tres capas de
carne diferente yo me acuerdo que había
que él había explicado que era el ars
alce
llevaba al se llevaba al fue el ternero
ahern era y no me acuerdo la otra carne
pero en todo caso es todo eso creo que
es
son tres tipos sin distintos de cantidad
puede ser carne de animal silvestre como
puede ser la presencia de zhanjiang son
yo sé que son tres carnes porque todavía
me quedó grabado a ganar dice si puede
ser el fácil del parto del pacto ahí
dice nuestra colega que está detrás ahí
controlando los andar siempre
controlando los manejando los hilos
botones técnicos gracias a tal y
entonces me acordé de eso hoy ahora y me
dio hambre porque
justamente se hizo en el sun ya han
hecho una tour quiere mostrar de
leonardo la foto más grande
es impresionante el récord mira esta
paloma vez batió el récord guinness ayer
es una parte de casi mil kilos
novecientos sesenta y dos kilos y que
medía 12 metros de largo y comieron dos
mil personas de buscar o es que sabes
que es la mejor tortilla la mejor vida
alcanza carnes de quebec y lo he probado
por creo que de canadá por puede ser
típica con desastres cada vez que es lo
rico de esa de sap de esa
particularmente es que la carne no está
molida no está cortada
exacto no es muy corta dicen así también
tiene que ser corto
las empanadas de leonora son cosas que
nunca olvida jamás porque significa la
calidad de la carne es más jugosa porque
guarda el jugo mientras que la la plaza
es molida pues se pierde a mí lo que me
mato una vez fui a comprar además no
sabes nunca que carne hay nada no ir ahí
eso me preocupa siempre ahí va
justamente fui una vez nos habíamos
quedado sin carné para los típicos
argentinos que hacemos nosotros que aquí
conseguimos cuatro cortes uno de ellos
es la entraña que es un corte súper
sabroso y se viene con dos tipos de
peritos peritos piel arriba y abajo con
una cocina es una exquisita son
realmente manjar fui a pedir la una a
una
carnicería local no la usamos para la
carne molida
no se conseguía acá no existían acerca
de molida porque como no es un corte que
se venda o no ahora
hay algunos lugares no se consigue yo
creo que ya está dos argentinos de
montreal han hecho que aparezca que
además traían quedó congelado de
argentina si no me quieren momentos y
ahora ve los que la compran la compran
directamente desde alberta tienen y
hacen productos ya saben cortarla porque
cada vez a causa de los line en
migración justamente que no sólo sólo no
sólo son los argentinos también los
chiles y mucho a saville estos días
tienen más abajo
y también tiene aparte de la carne tiene
otros rellenos que no me acuerdo ya pero
había papas si no me equivoco pedacitos
hemos llegado al final vamos a almorzar
hay algo que les llamó la atención
además a ustedes algunos de ustedes si
yo tengo un horario donde cuentan cosas
muy graciosas en este caso es un
pueblito también eeuu donde había un
hueco un pozo en una calle hacía más de
un año y la persona que vivía en la
esquina llamaba constantemente y los
vecinos también a la especialidad para
arreglarla y durante un año no
respondieron de conciencia vamos a
evitar morir no fueron un día peligroso
es peligroso aparte pero el ruido esto
supongo que la mujer lo hacía por el
ruido porque cuando un auto entra un
pobre de amd velocidad de ola frenó la
frenada
bueno no había logrado que fueran y este
año tomó la decisión fue se acercó al
pozo lo limpió le sacó todo puso tierra
y clavó un árbol de navidad
para que la gente por lo menos lo
esquivara con dulces con todo el mismo
día bailando los tristes
yo creo que es una buena manera
manera pero lo hubieran dejado para esta
navidad ya que se vio el trabajo hay que
dejarlos el 6 de enero y no me vienen a
la mente en este momento bueno nosotros
tenemos ya estuvimos hablando un poco la
semana pasada de los tiempos de fiestas
de las navidades y una noticia que
sacaste paloma y que me sorprendió tal
vez no debería sorprender me llamas es
que un cuarto de los canadienses
excederá su presupuesto navideño si van
a gastar más de lo que tienen y según
esa noticia que hiciste el 8 por ciento
le va a llevar un año es una deuda que
locura estacionalidad es y ya no es lo
que era antes no no a mí también me
sorprendió porque es 26 por ciento de
los canadienses eso estarían
sobrepasando el límite que se abrían
ellos mismos sin impuestos en cuanto a
los gastos de navidad encuesta en cuanto
a los gastos para los regalos de navidad
la cena de navidad es decir la para el
período de las fiestas navideñas y lo
más interesante bueno no sé si es bueno
o malo lo más interesante es que está
con esta encuesta que fue realizada por
una compañía que es una compañía privada
pero que en realidad hace mucho trabajo
de educación financiera y que da todas
las opciones posibles que se llaman low
straits punto o sea que es decir
encontrar las mejores las mejores cuotas
cogí una foto porque me sentía así al
leer la noticia de lo que explicaba es
que le sorprendía mucho haber y estaban
muy contentos de ver que los canadienses
habían adoptado la práctica de preparar
un presupuesto para las fechas navideñas
la idea es que tendrían que haberlo
respetado bueno quiere decir que la
mayoría lo respeta porque bueno
solamente 26 solamente bueno por si es
un cuarto de la población es igual a
cerca del 35 por ciento la gente está
endeudada además en general sí
exactamente entonces que explicaban
perdón 47 35
entonces esa gente lo que hace es
sobrepasar su presupuesto que esa gente
a lo mejor nos tenemos que incluir
algunos en él pero que tiene que pedir
la casilla señalando ahí esa gente se
gasta la plata es una forma de controlar
tienen que ir a pedir al banco prestado
para pagar y después las tarjetas de
crédito con tarjetas de crédito y no
tienen una práctica que nosotros
aplicamos
que es de pagar rápidamente nuestra
tarjeta de crédito eso es lo que hay que
hacer no es humano no es utilizar la
tarjeta de crédito sino pagar la clase
en 2000 dólares y después paga el mínimo
por lo menos parte lo interesante es que
si uno hace por ejemplo lo compre una
computadora sale 500 dólares y pagó el
mínimo hasta que yo no cancele la
totalidad de los 500 dólares los
intereses son sobre los 500 aunque yo no
robo
nadie me obliga a utilizarla sobre el
precio que no ponemos un negocio de
tarjetas de crédito que es el tema
justamente de esta semana que los que
más dinero hacen son justamente las
instituciones financieras seguro admiten
umbral de crédito es cierto de que
nosotros pagamos
un porcentaje si no pagas tu tarjeta de
acta donde recibes la cuenta pues vas a
pagar los intereses pero no es con los
intereses que las compañías que las
instituciones financieras que emiten la
tarjeta de crédito hacen su dinero
aunque es que los comerciantes tienen y
se calcula que un comerciante asia
alrededor gana alrededor de 4 por ciento
de todo lo vendido de ese 4% le ellos le
tienen que pagar un 2% a las
instituciones bancarias tienen que el
que los coles
no lo hacen con nosotros sino con los
comercios con los comerciantes en gran
parte y con nosotros también porque
pagan los intereses caramba ellos no
pierden los hilos los bancos nunca
pierden y las instituciones de seguros
son las otras que tampoco nunca pierden
no exactamente entonces es un poco el lo
que hay una gran campaña digamos a nivel
canadiense
para que la gente se eduque más
financieramente y creo que se podría
extender a todo el mundo porque en
américa latina también la utilización de
las tarjetas es excesivo entonces hay
que tener mucho cuidado con lo que uno
compra y sobre todo con lo que uno no
paga a tiempo sobre esas esos préstamos
que nos hacen en los bancos
entonces el periodo de fiesta no es tan
bueno para todos pero muy bueno para
todos los bancos los comerciantes que
también porque finalmente quiénes son
los que terminan pagando son los
consumidores o sea el comerciante el
comerciante le paga porque tú pagas con
tu tarjeta de crédito al comercio pero
entonces la institución financiera le
cobra ese porcentaje al comerciante por
recibir esa tarjeta de crédito y los
comerciantes calculan eso en el precio
de los colores o hay negocios aquí y
hubo un movimiento en un momento dado me
acuerdo también de negocios de adherir a
ese principio de no aceptar cartas de
crédito en los restaurantes o en otros
negocios que me imagino que no funciona
muy bien porque la gente está tan
acostumbrada a pagar con carta del
crédito ni ante nadie tremendo o pagar
con la tarjeta del banco o no
todo eso sería la solución tal vez no
en fin en realidad la solución es
hacer las compras con funciones del
salario en función del dinero que uno
cree tener porque tiene 5
sería una buena elección para los países
que piden préstamos al fondo monetario
por gente imagina drogas es lo que
tenemos lo que no tenemos entonces
llegar a canadá no tenía tarjeta de
crédito no conocía eso decir si mi
familia también para tener acceso a una
carta de crédito más difícil más difícil
para que se endeude si quiero ir a
méxico tengo que comprar con tarjeta de
crédito mis boletos de avión
tampoco poco si quiero rentar un auto
muchas cosas con la tarjeta de crédito
requieren sí sí sí entonces te han
entrampado sí señor aunque si eres
disciplinado yo pago absolutamente todo
con tarjeta de crédito porque aquí
cuando el fin de año a fin ya fin de mes
cuando llega la cuenta a la pago
completa retribuye le retribuye yo tengo
una tarjeta de crédito que me quemé
retribuye a mí un 1% de lo que yo estoy
gastando si entonces estás estás
ahorrando incluso estoy ahorrando de
alguna forma de tal forma que eso por
ejemplo me voy a ir a cuba en la
primavera con lo que haya ahorrado con
los puntos de la tarjeta de los pasajes
existe una noticia que a mí me llamó la
atención y es algo que nunca había
escuchado hablar un boxeador mexicano
saúl canelo álvarez suyo subió de peso
si es que van directamente de nosotras
en lo que a los que les gusta el boxeo
saben que las categorías que existen de
mediano de un montón y eso depende
exacto
del boxeador
entonces este boxeador saúl el canelo
álvarez decidió tomó la decisión de
aumentar dos kilos de peso para subir de
categoría para ir a desafiar al campeón
de esa categoría que es un inglés que se
llama
building
el tema de subir dos kilos de músculo
porque él no sube dos kilos de grasa
y por qué y por qué todo ese esfuerzo
porque ya es campeón mundial en dos
categorías y quieres ir ahora a pelear
con este campeón de los medianos ligeros
para ser campeón mundial en tres
categorías que forma una especie de club
selecto mexicano en el cual ya está
julio julio césar chávez marco antonio
barrera y juan manuel márquez que fueron
campeones en 33 categorías con hollywood
al bajo que van a subir de peso entonces
pues él hizo eso y el combate es este
sábado el 15 de mayo mañana en el en el
madison square garden de nueva york así
de qué es
[Música]
mañana sí pero a pesar de todo su
promotor su entrenador que es otro ex
boxeador se llama óscar de la hoya
y él dice que bueno que no va a ser
fácil no hacer fácil para el canelo esta
pelea porque el inglés el rock y field
building es un gran cambio es un
golpeador es un duro más alto que él y
está en su categoría a ya mí me dan
miedo que los que nos llamen en la
imagen se ve la diferencia de altura
entre fildean a la derecha y el mexicano
pero es sobre lo que uno dice son más
bajitos pero son bajitos tienen una
habilidad para para ir se puede ir a
golpearlo en lugares estratégicos pero
no está bien
y hablando de eso después de la persona
que casi muere que quedó en coma lo que
me contó que había visto un médico
hablando diciendo que esta sociedad está
de la cabeza completamente loca porque
en las reglas del box está completamente
prohibido peatón elementales pero que le
peguen en la cabeza uno no es ningún
problema o se deja punto pero que pueda
tener puede seguir teniendo sexo entre
él decía es más difícil este médico
decía que una sociedad en la que se
permite que ese golpe el ser el cerebro
y que te provoque una conmoción cerebral
porque el nocaut ese exceso es una
conmoción cerebral y sé que te protege
que te protege los genitales pero que no
te protege la cabeza es una sociedad
tiene sean que hay en la que algo anda
mal
chistes de aquellos que los hombres que
se ponían las mujeres se ponen prótesis
mamarias y los hombres que toman viagra
y dentro de 30 años no son acordar para
qué pero van a tener los pechos bien
paraditos y una muy buena elección
[Risas]
y lo bueno cada vez que mi hijo
cualquier deporte accidente con blando
es ese ser el hockey también si mi hijo
de juega a joaquín lo bueno es que no
juega no es tan bueno como para jugar
una categoría que ella haya en contacto
porque él está en la categoría aaa pero
si fuera w w
porque ella es un joven de 15 años
entonces te imaginas en esa categoría a
partir de la categoría midget casi
última antes de la última puesto
profesional o que antes bueno sí
exacto en esa categoría como están tan
grandes pues hay una es una categoría
que va de los 15 a los 18 años y a veces
hay diferencias entre chicos de de 15
en la fuerza en el músculo entonces yo
estoy muy contenta que no sea tan
también un deporte violento eso estoy en
mí e incluso cuando no es tienen
contacto con algunos de los equipos son
están entrenados para ir a entrar en
contacto con ellos porque no los quieren
permitir hacer goles es normal y como va
muy rápido el hockey sobre hielo el
problema principal es la velocidad a la
que se mueven porque si fue el pasado
otros deportes también pero estábamos
rápidos y entonces hay algún mensaje o
algo no no lo tenemos nos escucha
si no se escuchan termina en facebook
que tenía este pero lo estoy checando
funciona para solucionar por la gente
que habitualmente se unan a nuestra
transmisión no está hoy así que yo creo
que tiene que ver te van a aparecer
están a aparecer después o están pero no
se manifiestan ahora a mí lo que me lo
que me llamó un poquito también
manera la atención y que es algo que va
a suceder mañana también pero esta vez
lejos de américa del norte es en el
bolshói de rusia por primera vez
por primera vez un quebequense fue
invitado a como estrella pues a
participar de este famosísimo ballet del
bolshói él va a actuar va a jugar él va
a interpretar el papel de romeo en el
teatro bolshói mismo es guión cote
empezó según un poco estuve viendo su
historia a bailar a los tres años viene
de una familia de bailarines es se
convirtió en bailarín estrella en el
2004 en el valle de los el canadiense
ballet nacional de canadá y pues este
sábado va a estar hasta nadie va a
actuar en sala llena ya se vendieron
todas las entradas va a actuar va a ser
el único norteamericano si se quiere
todo el resto es el valer ruso son todos
los rusos bajo la dirección del
coreógrafo que es bastante conocido
alexei ratmansky y el director de
orquesta no si tienes si tienes el valor
nueva york que tuvo varios ballet y el
día el director de orquesta para del
clínic soft y me encanta el ballet a mí
también y además de esto sí que es
hermoso de verlo bailar estuve viendo
algunos vídeos es impresionante y de la
foto no más de arriba fíjate y la otra
así salgo yo de la cama todos los días
[Risas]
tiene un poco de expresión
el temor de la caída
pues esa foto me impresiona puedes
realmente uno puede ver su cuerpo en esa
extensión de piernas y brazos
es impresionante entonces bueno es un
que me canse encinar mañana tenemos acá
este tema el bolshói al mexicano
exacto bueno y aquí seguimos nosotros en
este momento para los que nos están
escuchando que alguien está por ahí los
que están en sus casas en los taxis en
el trabajo paseando saludos y suerte
saludos saludos y saludos desde la
soleada bogotá
siempre con eso con ese mensaje que nos
provocó muchísimo sol ayer no entiende
es una lámpara no es cierto no basta
leonardo
5 es el ejercicio de la foto
llamando al 911 de atraer esta mañana
una niñita de nueve años en calgary creo
que llamó al 911 porque su mamá lo
obligaba a limpiar la pieza
así están mis hijos a punto de
usted es limpiar su casa niñita es la
ley injustamente en sí vice del sitio
porque era es para es para reírse para
no llorar porque lo que decía fueron a
la casa de ella investigar esa llamada
tienen que ir están obligados aunque
haya llamado porque le quiten a obligar
a limpiar la pieza pero lo que
explicaban después es que cuando que hay
que tener cuidado con los hijos y
explicarles y le explicaron a la niña
que cuando ella llama hay personas que
se movilizan detrás de esta llamada
multa y que dejan de pueden dejar de
atender a alguien que realmente necesita
porque no saben si lo que está diciendo
es un chiste o hay algo que está más que
está pasando no me hizo reír un poquito
si yo tengo a alguien que conozco a
alguien que llamo porque había ruidos
extraños en la casa al lado y en la casa
al lado se estaba viendo partido el
fútbol
y estaban gritando por el partido de
sí
la mujer habla por ti si está todo bien
si por qué no por qué pasa
y cuando pasaron a escuchar
al marido y el hijo gritando desde abajo
está gritando frente a la televisión
bueno pero ahí podría haber otra cosa
entonces ya me acordé que iba a decir
está porque estábamos hablando del sol
esta mañana iba bajando por esta hay una
bajadita una lomita que hay que bajar
para llegar a radio canadá y va bajando
y estaba el sol saliendo eran como las
siete y cuarto de la mañana de un sol
enorme que venía de él la imagen unido
al frente del sol solamente era tan
grande pensé que era una de una lámpara
justamente el efecto óptico gracias a la
cómo es posible que será tan gigante el
efecto de
cuando da vuelta por la forma de la
tierra cuando baja el
la atmósfera de una condensación de
atmósfera en el horizonte entonces
cuando están en el horizonte ser mucho
más grandes cuando suben en tamaño
original
y eso venía bueno desde el río san
lorenzo que está justo a un lado de
radio canadá no pero entonces se veía
tan hermoso como funciona solamente en
colombia porque ni con él lo encontré
rincón dice saludos para todos desde
barranquilla colombia muy bien bueno
vamos a leer un poco los mensajes que
hubo un reclamo la semana pasada y un
javier garay sí así que dije lo leemos
nada no es que se dijo me parece que la
señora eleonora se olvidó las de leer
las cartas en realidad tenía razón
el tema es que me olvidé de traer la
carpeta
[Aplausos]
entonces la puse a perseguir la puse a
vista javier y a graves entonces estaba
atento javier vamos entonces con los
mensajes sigo aquí tengo uno que dice
jóvenes con esquizofrenia en canadá
faltos de tratamiento consecuencias y
álex se nos dice posible que un hombre
con esquizofrenia se descubre y es
hereditaria se dice que al padre de mi
hija se le diagnosticó esquizofrenia que
cometió ciertos crímenes en méxico y
estuvo internado en canadá la cara brand
como su familia es adinerada no le
hicieron nada
ahora tengo miedo porque la fuerza
quiere que mi hija se quede con él y
también el tema por la seguridad de mi
actual familia sobre todo de mi pequeño
disco hace cuatro meses podrían ayudarme
lamentablemente no podemos ayudar de
ninguna manera pero bueno es bastante
complicado el tema de la esquizofrenia
hoy en día tengo que el mensaje de
javier gonzález nunca
y me estoy leyendo tu mensaje naufragio
de un barco de emigrantes deja 99
muertos y 25 desaparecidos y javier con
comenta de acuerdo a los datos
proporcionados por la onu un millón 650
mil migrantes han migrado a la unión
europea en los años 2015 2016 y 2017 es
una cantidad muy considerable además de
lo que acarrea para los países que lo
reciben porque no todos participan en
europa estos naufragios que son muy
constantes son una tristeza porque entre
esa gente hay niños y personas mayores
salu2 rufo supongo que fue rufo que hizo
el suelo el artículo del post ag gracias
a javier javier gonzález nungaray tablet
y bueno si yo tengo acá bueno digamos
que el invierno comenzó temprano en
algunos lugares de canadá y esto fue en
calgary justamente el 8 de octubre que
es donde cayó una tormenta famosa 40 cm
de nieve en solo 12
es un récord de más de 100 años se batió
ahí entonces javier gonzález nungaray
justamente escribí dice apenas empiezan
los cambios de estación y se nota de
inmediato el cambio de clima lo que me
extraña es que es muy repentino como el
de este reportaje de calgary acá en
méxico también empezamos a notar cambios
saludos a todos los buenos amigos de
radio canadá internacional allá en
montreal y era javier gonzález nunca
hemos muy bien yo tengo algo acá sobre
un comentario de vaquero de calgary
llega a su ciudad natal después de dos
años a caballo me acuerdo de esto y es
aníbal con h que dice h al final y al
inicio dice que magnífico viaje a
caballo soy de argentina y también
realizó marchas a caballo es una cosa
fantástica para los que gustamos de la
aventura al aire libre y de los caballos
y yo me acuerdo de este de esta nota que
fue hace mucho tiempo ya y que era un
brasileño que vivía en calgary wing
había llegado a canadá de niño
y creo que me lo este canadiense en
calgary sí claro y se hizo el viaje
desde calgary hasta brasil no sé cuáles
tres caballos llevaban tres caballos
dedos de recambio y 131 si estoy no
llevan tanto peso pero le llevo dos años
pero increíble ese viaje que me subía
además el chico éste era un periodista
así que escribió parece notas muy
interesante entonces este comentario de
argente en tema
las sonrisas
seguimos leonard aquí tengo otro mensaje
es de luis quijano tolosa sobre la
información la causa de la caravana de
migrantes son las políticas de eeuu en
honduras y louis se nos dice esta
noticia no la he visto que se difunden
los medios mexicanos y que ayuda a
aclarar la causa real que produce la
migración de hondureños hacia eeuu esta
situación de lo que ha ocurrido
realmente durante años en ese país es
casi desconocida o se ha ocultado la
opinión pública internacional encuentro
este reportaje bastante ilustrativo y
veraz luis quijano tolosa y bien yo
tengo acá un mensaje que nos envía
justamente andrés chartrand y no es sólo
en colombia donde nos están escuchando
en facebook porque a andrés ya atrás nos
escribe aquí en facebook y dice saludos
desde la asunción que beck
no lo saben pero aprendí mucho del
español
escuchándoles que bien por eso
muchísimas gracias a todos y todas
andrés ar tratar es el más gracias
andrés qué bueno
me gusta y hablando de quebequenses el
mensaje de un quebequense de un
reportaje quienes se benefician más los
comerciantes o las instituciones que
emiten las tarjetas de crédito y jill de
creer dice muy interesante muchas
gracias también de que vengan que siguen
muchos y aquí tengo un mensaje
[Risas]
nelson contras rincón dice pablo si dios
quiere seremos campeones el domingo con
tu yunís
[Música]
en la final que final del torneo
colombiano a de corno
cuando uno solo
tengo mensajes mónica con k qué pregunta
tiene la atención médica en toronto y
pregunta esto porque está haciendo
referencia a un artículo que se escribió
aquí en radio canadá internacional sobre
la clínica para migrantes sin cobertura
médica de médicos del mundo canadá y
bueno en toronto no sabemos nada pero
además toronto incluso creo que estaba
más adelantado que montreal en un
momento dado sobre el tema de las
personas sin papeles y atención médica y
escuelas extrañamente pero ahora fíjate
que lo que hemos lo que hemos estado
viendo últimamente es que en términos de
médicos probablemente que estén más
avanzados en toronto pero la nueva
política de word no la política aquí en
quebec sobre el axel acceso a los
servicios está cambiando está cambiando
y esto es incluso mejor
de médicos del mundo a quien es de
montreal
muy bien tengo otro mensaje longevidad
no sería hereditaria como se creía dice
tienen williams mil excelente enfoque
pero necesario leer el trabajo para ver
qué metodología utilizaron obviamente
las parejas comparten una mente común
que los conducirá o conduciría a llevar
hábitos similares pero como calcula la
red y de habilidad de los individuos que
no están emparentados esa es la pregunta
que nos deja vienen en nuestro sitio
internet vamos a dejar un poco para el
final los los comentarios de nuestros
oyentes por si nos queda tiempo que creo
que si nos va a quedar un poco y vamos a
los temas que destacamos esta semana
cada uno de nosotros voy a ir con nuevos
leonardo tienes como siempre tus temas
bien tecnológicos y dices que policía
planta dispositivos de gps en cajas de
amazon y esto con el objetivo de d
bueno de evitar que se roben las cajas
porque amazon tiene un sistema muy
particular aquellos que aunque son
socios de los no socios creo que también
pero particularmente los socios de un
plan especial que se llama prime prime
hacer el envío con sólo 24 horas o sea
yo compro hoy mañana el paquete está
bien pero como tienen un montón de
suscriptores y tienen que hacer un
montón de entregas lo que hacen es tocar
el timbre y deja el paquete y si van o
no y no siempre hay gente en la casa o
sea que el paquete puede pasar ocho
horas hasta que vuelva la persona del
trabajo o desaparecer que es una
invitación a la cleptomanía entonces la
historia es bastante simple
amazon no le importa porque el seguro le
cubre pero la historia es que cada vez
son más los los clientes quienes
apuestan al ver clientes entonces aquí y
lo que propuso fue gracias a una campaña
que está iniciando una en una ciudad de
estados unidos en nueva jersey están
intentando hacer bajar los niveles de
robos de las cajas de amazon entonces
pidieron a con la colaboración de amazon
y amazon envio cajas vacías y metieron
gps adentro
donde supuestamente se roban más las
cajas de envíos de amazon entonces
también que se roben en canadá también
se roban se hace un par de semanas
dijeron que el lugar donde más se roba
se en el oeste la isla donde lo vivo las
cosas y bueno todavía este plan
solamente se hace new yersey hay plan
similares en otras dos ciudades eeuu
pero no se ha expandido por todo el
mundo donde funciona a amazon prime pero
la historia es que hay que tener cuidado
porque esto pasa está pasando se están
robando la y sobre todo este plan fue
instaurado efectivamente porque es
increíble la cantidad que vende amazon
durante la época de fiestas en canadá
amazon vende sobre todo cuestiones que
tienen que ver con dispositivos
electrónicos en eeuu es uno de los
mayores de ventas en todos
y empezó vendiendo solamente libros y
ahora vende cuál
cosa que uno puede hacer las compras del
supermercado en amazon está bien
entonces la gente se roba los paquetes y
esta es una de las maneras que están
haciendo como decíamos y van a endeudar
ante la pobreza el paquete que yo pedí o
que envíe a alguien de regalo es que
amazon me va a compensar sí y como
tienen la prueba de que me los robaron
como tengo yo la perdono robe a mí misma
a mí me pasó una vez yo pedí es
justamente el aparatito para proteger el
reloj que ortelli hermosillo nada y lo
pedí y no me digo llamé por teléfono a
amazon y mejor le devolvemos el dinero
me devolvieron el dinero el reloj lo
habían dejado en la casa de al lado y mi
vecino me lo trajeron esté equivocado
evidentemente ya me amazon y le dije
cobre me lo ponga mi futuro está
así que no llegó
yo cuando fui a tu casa los vecinos
porque si no tienes 30 años menos que no
tendrá 32
bienvenido
y mirar que claro bueno entonces seguido
por los temas pablo vos estás
presentando una una remera o una
vestimenta bien en particular fabricada
por una compañía quebequense y que
además esta vestimenta ya fue al espacio
también de que se trae exacto
también el espacio va a durar va a durar
allá seis meses y medio porque está la
está vistiendo de david saint jacques
que es este astronauta canadiense que
salió la semana pasada hacia hacia la
estación espacial internacional y bueno
no tenía conocido de esta empresa de
esta compañía quebequense que que
fabrica ropa inteligente esté dentro de
la de la tela
con la que fabrican estos esta ropa
tienen dispositivos que permiten
calcular el ritmo cardíaco la
respiración
efe la temperatura como los relojes como
todas estas máquinas que busquen que te
por la que tiene uno que pasa cuando le
van a hacer un electrocardiograma y todo
esto no salvo de que eso está integrado
en la ropa lo llevas en el cuerpo y
excepto esos dispositivos envían una
señal a la nasa y en este caso no porque
hablamos de las zonas estamos hablando
de la vista en ya que porque tienen una
obligación de confidencialidad para eso
no pero ellos también venden ropa
deportiva y la idea de ellos es que está
este tipo de ropa se ha utilizado por la
mayor parte de gente posible que tienen
problemas de salud uno de los problemas
que hay aquí en este momento es que los
hospitales y las emergencias están
todo el tiempo están completamente
desbordados si tú vas a una emergencia
tienes que prepararte para pasar por lo
menos ocho o diez obras ahí entonces
esto que ellos proponen es que no
necesitas ir a la sala de urgencias sino
que ese dispositivo que con la prenda de
vestir que tú tengas encima va a enviar
las señales a tu médico
no entiendo por el astro nada estando
entonces los deportistas hay deportistas
utilizando no es no es ciencia ficción
de ciencia realidad ese se está
sucediendo hoy en día los deportistas de
élite me imagino que debe ser bastante
costosa no sé si no son accesibles
haciendo la comparación en los gastos
que se que se invierten digo en la salud
y lo que podría economizarse si en vez
de ir al hospital a la emergencia la
camiseta que tiene expuesta envía tus
señales a tu médico
a quien interese pues se avanza mucho y
le sirve
muy muy interesante pues espero algún
día poder usarla yo también cuando esté
más barata más accesible porque ahora
eso debe estar muy lejos de los
bolsillos comunes y corrientes paloma
vos nos hablas de miradas transversales
panorama de la escena artística latino
que ubiquen se es una compilación
leonora de textos escritos por los
escritos por varios investigadores por
varias personas de la comunidad
latinoamericana de la provincia de
québec y que fueron compilados por
maritza a cargo a cargo argonz a rosales
yo te la mando en el papel sí y es es
una compilación entonces de textos
escritos por varias personas que tienen
conocimiento digamos de la historia de
la comunidad artística latinoamericana y
es una colaboración con un festival del
cual ya les hemos hablado aquí en la
cnel en el programa latín arte que
justamente lo que necesita lo que hacen
es hacer conocer la presencia artística
latinoamericana en la provincia de
québec particularmente en la ciudad de
montreal
entonces el reportaje el reportaje el
libro de marisa de mar y sagrados
rosales arganza que es artista visual e
investigador de la universidad de quebec
en montreal lo que nos presenta es
justamente una serie de textos de gente
que que desde los años 50 viene
observando cómo funciona y la presencia
musical la presión nuevo canto en todo
perfectamente entonces la relación
nos tenemos que despedir chao chao y
transversales- ese es el nombre de este
texto entonces muy bien pero quizás la
una noche de audio
presión presentó un tema que científicos
descubren bajo el hielo uno de los
mayores cráteres de la tierra causado
por un meteorito y que uno siempre habla
de estos meteoritos que pues en el
yucatán era hace 60 millones de años con
los dinosaurios que se fueron estilo
pero hay otros y este es un cráter y lo
interesante de estos dicen los
científicos es que no tendría millones
de años desde que sucedió se sitúa entre
3.000 y 12.000 años una cosa así un poco
con un poco más entonces más reciente es
mucho más reciente calculan 12 mil años
eso no a la ciencia le interesa mucho
que surgieron los seres humanos ya
estaban los seres humanos ya estaban
caminando incluso ya está ahora entonces
los científicos se reflejan las manos
porque están van a empezar
investigaciones que creen que los puede
llevar para resolver enigmas que hasta
el momento no están resueltos y ahora
la próxima